there's a Twilight feel to one of the
main indoor markets in downtown Caracas
but it's actually the middle of the day
like everywhere else in the entire
country
there is no power the only light is in
the fishmongers they're the only ones
here with a generator
the butcher's shops are mainly shuttered
and empty in some though the meat is
just rotting away
fruit and vege is available but only
with a bank card if they can get a
signal or US dollars the country's
hyperinflation means there's basically
no local money certainly not enough you
could find to pay for anything Rosa
Gonzalez says this is a disaster the
fruit and vegetables are rotting without
light and coolers we are accepting
dollars
lots of people come with dollars we're
also accepting euros and bank transfers
sometimes we let people take the food
and come back and pay another day and if
they don't come back well that's how it
is
everyone is affected in Venezuela and
there's a sort of numb chalk in everyone
we meet when you go to this kind of
Mercado do you they shall you be fooled
by the visas all cars money cut and
nobody have cash now some of these
places you know I have been have three
days without water without food without
TV without a place here and also with
our communication this is now the
longest nationwide power outage in world
history what was normally considered an
absolute given in this society is
falling apart and not slowly
this is the country with the largest
known reserves of oil in the world they
barely charge for it
but without power you can't get it it
sort of priceless now this is the queue
for one of the garages with a generator
it's miles long driving around the city
it's easy to see how things can fall
apart long tunnels and out-pitch done
Communications and telephone systems
have collapsed on motorways cars simply
pull over if they find a place with a
signal people now stand in line outside
supermarkets not to go in they're just
hoping that it will eventually open the
political chaos here could soon be
eclipsed by this increasingly dangerous
national disaster still Rowsey Sky News
corrects